You guys don't remember Rob's Media made the original kind of
like hit piece on YMS. It was fairly poorly constructed. The
the arguments were quite bad.
The arguments were quite bad essentially the whole time. Uh basically
the real argument here is Adam's kind of a degenerate. He is
sorry kind of he's absolutely a degenerate. He's kind of he's
a weirdo. He might do some he might do some arguing online or
used to do some arguing online that was a little cringe. He says
some crazy.
Um
yeah, I don't know if he's necessarily going to harm people.
I don't think he should do the arguments he was doing. Seems
like he's mostly stopped,
but he does have that little bit of autism in him that he thinks
he's correct, right? And he's So he thinks he's correct. And
if pushed on it, I think he could be pushed to defend himself.
So we'll see. will watch this and then maybe we check Twitter,
see if there's any follow from this this video being posted cuz
I I'm expecting YMS to come post under this video at some point.
All right, I'm expecting it. There's going to be Rob copy the
Nandros video. Well, I know Nandros had showed him the VOD or
whatever, so there will be stuff from that other VOD in this
video. I'm guessing he's going to want to make some of his own
arguments, too. Uh, the big thing that kind of annoyed me about
the previous video, my main criticism was that he seemed to use
Vos and Destiny. Like, he seemed to web Adam onto Vos and Destiny
without like a lot of evidence other than you talk about weird
[__] that makes me uncomfortable. They talk about
weird [__] that makes me uncomfortable. Like essentially,
so there's two arguments. It's like, yeah, that and then I didn't
connect the dots. He says, you know, quote unquote, I didn't
connect the dots on like Destiny talking about like young people
and then having a relationship over text with a 17-year-old.
I didn't I didn't take it seriously when Vos talked about young
people and then he had, you know, approached a minor as well
in Discord. So So
Rob's basically saying now I'm going to take it seriously with
Adam and I'm going to consider him like somebody who abuses Adam
or sorry animals. Adam, somebody who abuses animals also himself
with whatever those videos are that are on that that furry NSFW
account. Okay. Absolutely crazy. Scan the video timeline thumbnail
and you'll know what the video is. Uh why why do I want to spoil?
Why wouldn't I just want to watch it? I just want to watch it,
man. >> I hate this guy. I hope he suffers. I hope he loses
every >> Oh, Kino Casino. Kino Casino watched it. Yeah,
Kino Casino not going to have any charity for you, buddy. Kino
Casino, they they hear you are a furry and they're going to bury
you. >> He belongs in prison. I I also think for for Wars
and PvP, I would imagine the the couple, you know, seconds of
clip from Adam being on Idubbbz and An's podcast. I'm guessing
that totally totally [__] them or totally [__]
Adam. Okay. In their eyes,
>> go get some puppy. You are sick. You need help. I don't
think we should put you down like a puppy yet. But actually,
I don't know. >> It always comes back to Shad, man. any
one of these [__] degenerates, it always somehow
goes back to >> who's this person? I don't know who this
person is. Oh, it's Kristen Arc. Oh, I know. I just don't know
his face. I know who Kristen Arc is. I just don't know the face.
>> Man, these two >> just stop. Just please stop.
>> The the path of a free speech absolutist is to get dragged
into a conversation, look like veto just Waldi. >> So,
your movie sucks actually commented on this video. I wonder if
it's still there. You knowingly created a situation where I HAVE
TO PHYSICALLY HURT MYSELF TO give a proper response.
>> Listen, your movies. >> Oh, I didn't read all
of those YouTube replies and I'm guessing they're funny. I'm
assuming that's his RSI he's talking about. I had to physically
hurt myself to type into my phone enough to respond.
Oh, unfortunate. >> Docs, the bulls that they have aren't
literal bulls. You know that, right? >> Mhm. So, a little
while ago, I made a video detailing the depravity of your movie
sucks. A movie reviewer on YouTube who has a history of playing
devil's advocate for being in Lollcon. He's claimed over and
over again that he's actually just arguing for more. >> I
don't think he played devil's advocate for lollycon. I I'm Dude,
the lollycon argument he had was just it's a drawing. It came
from your mind. You shouldn't be able to get arrested for it.
That was that was all he said, right? I'm almost positive that's
all he said. Uh, hold on. The I think the full quote was cuz
it bugged me the way he put it. He like leaned into the language.
I think he said drawn child. You shouldn't be arrested for having
drawn child or something. But then when he actually like said
what the position was, I felt like I was like, "Oh, I kind of
I do understand that when you say it that >> Consistency.
When in my opinion, he's partially doing it to justify his attraction
to cartoon animals. He's made numerous responses to me, which
are usually dark viper style essays where you can clearly tell
he's having an eternal meltdown. It's 14 pages. The first one
starts with him throwing as many excuses at the wall as possible.
Like claiming I maliciously released my video while he was at
some snobby film festival, as if I'm constantly tracking his
location. I'm honestly surprised this guy leaves his house at
all. He also mentions a recent carpal tunnel surgery, saying
that he was in excruciating pain for the 5 hours he wrote it.
His poor little wrists were crumbling apart at the seams. I mean,
I totally feel bad for him, guys. He needs those wrists to jerk
off to Lion. It reminds me of Jake Dittle at the hospital using
it to bait sympathy after he got exposed as a person. Adam also
claims he's likely a explaining that's the reason why he had
to make his responses so long had drawn out. >> That's
that's part of the reason why I think I might
is cuz I seem to have like some kind of like obsession with,
you know, needing to
feel like I I am able to convince people or correct the record
in some way of, you know, just
this would be more of an an OCD thing, right? I call it autism,
but this would technically be more of an OCD thing. It sounds
kind of suspiciously like what uh Kimmy Marie Anavar described,
right? Like that there's somebody on the internet who thinks
something that's wrong about them. They very very intensely feel
the need to correct the record. Being honest, cuz I know that
I'm not an abuser. I know that I'm not attracted to children.
I know that I'm not attracted to animals. I don't even jerk at
Lolly. I hate that that's now a thing that people think. >> Oh,
wow. I'm glad you clarify that, Adam. Maybe he is a, but it's
not an excuse for stating opinions. You're a 34 year old man,
Adam. Grow the up. Stop with this pity me. Your parlor tricks
don't work on me, you cuz I'm on too. And I'm not out here debating
why it's okay to suck doggy. And yes, I'll address the elephant
in the room, his short hair. Bro went to his barber and said,
"Yo, give me that Ana Jha cut." commentary YouTubers have no
>> there's no way that these people these people are so
obsessed with tying all of their criticism to somebody their
audience already hates. Like it's the weakest
most crutch in the world. You don't have to compare Adam. He's
literally a furry who's willing to say you shouldn't be put in
jail for lollycon. If you can't kill this guy's credibility in
commentary land, you suck. You don't have to tie him to Ansa.
Stop being stop being so lazy, okay? Stop being so lazy every
time. >> No idea what it is to work a normal job,
let alone put on a whole event. >> Now, the main thing
I wanted to respond to here is Adam's claims of me being a child
groomer and a yes, those are claims he attempts to make. This
is over the fact that I briefly showed his not safe for work
public Twitter account, using it to site where I found certain
images from that I obviously won't show on my video. Adam thinks
that simply mentioning it and describing posts on it means I'm
luring 13 to 17 year olds to content, which is moronic in multiple
different ways. For one, I have a content warning at the beginning
of all my videos. I've always had the mindset that older viewers
are watching my content, which is why I've covered various risque
topics over the years, like disturbing websites, dark history,
and more. It's just not something that comes across my mind,
>> which is why I also don't bother censoring only fans
usernames. Second, Adam mentions himself that miners can't access
his explicit content on Twitter as he's enabled settings that
block them from seeing it. >> And I pointed out uh so what
did he claim there about miners using like the thing to me? There's
there's a very easy way to tell if young people are accessing
your content, right? There's a good way that you should be able
to tell and that's just your YouTube data. Your an your analytics
should literally say what the ages are of the people who are
watching your
like immediately they >> I've always had the mindset that
older viewers are watching my content which is why I've covered
various >> older viewers. Okay. Yeah. You literally could
just show your analytics
cuz Ry Riyle's literally saying what about the Lego videos? I
don't know. Like you could argue that. When are those from for
one thing? Are they from like last month or are they extremely
old? But you you just know the answer. You have like a solid
answer on this. >> Risk topics over the years like disturbing
websites, dark history, and >> It's just not something
that comes >> like like Okay, you could you could say this.
I just don't know.
Like he's he's doing Lego reviews.
I don't know. 248 views on a Lego review. Like it's just not
substantial compared to his channel. This would be a horrible
argument to make to him in person. Like this is why you should
just ask for the analytics because you might get your actual
blown out if you were to make this argument with somebody and
they pull up a 248 view video and go, "Oh, you're convinced all
the miners are coming from this video." Could also just age restrict
your videos by default. I think age restricted videos do not
get advertisements so they don't get ads so you don't make money.
So you could say, "Yeah, you could just cut all of your revenue,
but then he'd probably pick a different topic." >> My mind,
which is why I also don't bother censoring only fans usernames.
Second, Adam mentions himself that miners can't access his explicit
content on Twitter as he's enabled settings that block them from
seeing it. >> And I pointed out in the comment section,
the settings that I have enabled on these websites ensure
that if there are miners
on the website, right, they don't have the ability to access
it. And I tested this yesterday, by the way. I tested this. I
created a fake account with like a 13-year-old
uh birthday or whatever just to test this out because I'm I take
this very seriously, right? I I created an account on this website
just to test it out. You cannot see any of the media displayed
on my page, right? So, how would I be allowing miners of my audience
to access these materials if you've put restrictions in place
to prevent that?
>> Okay. Uhhuh. It's about making like an effort for one
thing, right? This is just the Oh god, it's got to be battle
of the in this video. Um, how how are these people supposed to
see the of like this specific person if I don't if they if they've
restricted their account to 18 plus? How could they possibly
do that >> that from happening? >> Nobody. And that's
this guy's doing the argument. Okay.
Has the 18 plus like button click. Okay. Yeah. I'm pretty sure
17-year-olds can't figure that out. Okay. Okay, they can't figure
out how to get that get how to get past that. >> It makes
no sense. Trust me, I don't want to lead miners to that. I don't
want poor little Timmy to stumble across videos where Adam is
recreating Mr. Hands of Big Randy. And while yes, miners could
lie about the creating Mr. Hands of Big >> What I
And while yes, miners could lie about their age on Twitter to
access this stuff, the same thing can't happen on YouTube with
age restricted videos. So, his suggestion that I should do that
wouldn't matter at all, as minors are always going to find ways
to view this stuff. But Adam isn't exactly helping in this regard.
The third reason this is dumb is because Adam has done exactly
what he's accused me of, showing people in his audience where
explicit materials can be found. He did it in a 2022 video where
he watches the movie Prey, showing how to access a furry fetish
site. Why can't they use a professional movie budget for C? Wait,
wasn't this in the original video? >> Gee, for something
that's actually worthwhile, like predator. I should look some
up right now. >> Why is he Why is he putting this in the
the video again? >> None of these are what I wanted. See,
they put aliens in there, too. There's one with a demig. >> Oh,
wait. Or was this was this just Nicholas who brought this up?
Somebody brought this up. I remember watching this criticism.
I thought Rob brought it
>> The top one has they have like weirdly human eyes. It's
not bad animation, though. Holy [__] One of these
is 25 minutes long. It's probably a distress signal coming from
this ship. >> What the hell? >> Yes, I'm searching
up Predator. That's how invested I am in the film. >> By
his own logic that he set up to demonize me, this must make Adam
a groomer, right? Well, according to him in his video response,
it's okay because he wasn't showing. >> He's just going
to do he's going to do the precise Nicholas Dioro answer right
now. Okay, cool. >> A specific page on there, just the
website where you can find them. >> I don't describe any
of it. It's not on screen, right? And then one of my editors
who made this edited version of the video decided, okay, we're
going to make this into a little joke. They put the words E621,
which is not a specific page that leads to these images, right?
This is just a vague. This is like saying, oh exists, right?
I don't even know if the images there were like from E621. Could
have been on, I don't know, rule 34. Like you're allowed to say
rule 34 in a video, right? I didn't describe any of the these
images beyond saying, oh, a demigorgan's in one. Haha, that's
funny. I'm referencing that a website exists, right?
just saying, "Haha, funny." And then there's some images that
are so censored that I don't even know if they're like legit.
Like, I don't even know because they're censored to the degree
where like you can't tell. And that's the point, right? Where
like we there's no I don't even Yeah, there was no in the images
anyway. It was just like the the context of that image. This
is a little is a little rough cuz he went to a site to find them
for one thing and then I also he's going to say like, "Oh, well
there's no tax." You're just going to give them the opportunity
to go, well, there's which they almost certainly are. If they're
on that >> would have been, oh, they're just posing. There
weren't even Yeah, there weren't even any in the images that
were heavily censored. >> Okay. But it's clearly you refer
to it as predator.
>> Yeah. I I I don't know. It was such a It was such a
stupid little like
it was such a stupid line of dialogue to throw out there to just
get like give this guy like a free dunk back on you. >> I
didn't even show censored my video. I just mentioned the existence
of your account
context which >> Yeah, exactly. Exactly. Adam should have
just stopped at saying you described the I didn't >> he
is well aware of there's also this part in one of his Twitter
responses where he says leading people to real is not as bad
as draw even though both are at the end of the day. I'm not surprised
he made this argument seeing this is the same guy who plays devil's
advocate for lollycon. Another difference in his eyes is that
him showing off this website is clearly a joke but mine isn't
because well the joke is on him. It's not in the context of let's
shame this person, right?
It's not in that context. It's in the context of haha, this movie
is so boring that I'm going to look up. >> He doesn't like
the fact that it's not safe for a Twitter account was brought
up because Nicholas Dioro and I king shamed him. Why was it important
for you
to knowingly
direct
minors
towards 18 plus accounts of myself within the context of king
shaming and describing in detail who was going into what hole
and what race they are and saying here is where you should go
find them. Why was that important to you? >> It wasn't
important. I just wanted to kink shame you because it's funny
to me. You're a public figure, Adam. You've spent your 15 plus
year long career giving opinions on controversial subjects. If
you're going to do that and post videos of yourself getting blacked
on Twitter, people like me are going to mock you for that. >> I
I knew that's what it meant. God, >> [__] loser.
If you don't want to be made fun of like this, stop revealing
so many details of your personal life. You're a movie reviewer,
dude. >> For 2 years of my life, I tried to oppress it.
It wound up with me getting addicted to Crystal. Like, that was
not fun. But I'm a strong person. Like, I'm a sub. Like, I literally
can't get off to people that don't want me. >> We know,
dude. Oh, >> I I just I wish there was no way to know that
that one furry account was Adam. I just wish I wish he'd kept
that one nugget of detail to himself. Okay. >> Takes his
one look at you. No. >> Although, I guess you could say
if he did that and then it was revealed, people would go, "Oh,
I don't know. >> At the end of the day, I don't actually
think Adam >> I think maybe you should have to I don't
know if that argument works all the time cuz like even if he
kept it private, let's say that leaks, would would nobody do
the video? Would nobody ever mock this guy? Let's say he kept
it totally private. He never told anybody about himself getting
DPD by two black dudes in his horse outfit. Okay. What if what
if he'd never said that?
Or sorry, what if he never said that was him and then it got
leaked somehow? It got leaked against his will that it was him.
Is Rob or or conservatives online not going to still clown on
him for it? Is that is that all it is? Oh, well, you deserve
this because you made it public. I don't think so. I think they
all clown on him either way. And I I hate to say this, okay?
I hate to say it, but I think I think Destiny just shows you
that that's true, right? Like, oh, wait, no, it doesn't because
Destiny talked about sucking before the videos came out. I was
going to say people people would say like, "Oh, don't reveal
that stuff about yourself." But actually, he did reveal that.
Oh, well, try try to do a little little tie in there. >> Who
gives a [__] about >> people people
safety? >> He just wants to discredit my video before anyone
can see it by attacking my character. I mean, this guy is retweeting
people who are calling me a pedo. Oh, and what a anyone can see
it by attacking my character. I mean, this guy is >> uh
That's funny.
I Dude,
that's just funny that this person's like uh this person's in
chat sometimes and they say a lot of
Is this It sounds like they're knowingly distributing minor.
That's behavior and I don't like
Okay. Tweeting people who are calling me a Oh, and what a shock.
The person who's saying this is a Destiny Glazer. They're defending
him against his actual admission to having CCM material. But
no, I'm the people for mentioning Adam doing yet despite lying.
>> This this Rob guy is is this Rob guy going to make like
any arguments in his video that aren't just like you are just
like Destiny. You are Destiny. You are Vosch. You are Denims.
You are Ana Ja. You are you are you are you are all these people
>> to having CCM material. But no, I'm the people for mentioning
Adam doing. Yet, despite lying about me multiple times regarding
this, he is whining about how I won't pin his lengthy essay under
my video. Oh, and he wants me to heart it as well. Yeah, let
me heart the comment where he slanders me as a groomer. The fact
that I wouldn't do this drove him insane as he DM' me begging
for a skitso meltdown to be pinned. But this wasn't the reason
why I blocked him. I did so because he went as far as requesting
to follow my down to be pinned. >> Oh, hold on. Let's Let's
watch. Hey yo, I'm typing up a comment for your video that should
be sent later tonight or tomorrow. Let me know if you can pin
it for the sake of transparency. Thanks. All right. So, any update
on that pin comment or removing the part where you're directing
miners to nude images of myself? Not sure what the holdup is
here. I mean, maybe Adam's a little here. He's not like getting
rude about >> And but this wasn't the reason why I blocked
him. I did so because he went as far as requesting to follow
my girlfriend on Instagram, seemingly in order to send her a
DM, too. >> That's funny. I blocked him because he
I mean I know the answer based on your thumbnail but is your
girlfriend hot or maybe maybe this guy's a gooner. Okay, >> buddy.
She doesn't want to talk to you. She's busy playing Overwatch.
This to me crossed a bit of a line. I've had no interest in directly
engaging with him since. And really there is no point in doing
that. He'd rather smear me as a groomer because he thinks it's
a funny >> The guy who made the video refused to pin my
comment for transparency. And yes, in that comment, I say this
is grooming behavior and I call him out in all caps. And I, you
know, I do a little skitso, right? I was mad because I was typing
this as I was at TIFF in between, excuse me, running around watching
four movies a day in my comments in the exact same thread. I
give the most charitable interpretation. I go, "Here's exactly
what you did." And it's not a quippy soundbite. It's not a meme,
right? So anybody who's like, "Oh, wait. They showed the minors."
In the same thread goes, oh, okay, that's what he meant. Even
on Twitter. Even on Twitter, it's like within the same thread.
>> There's no use in arguing with him. He'd rather misinterpret
things than lie. I made this clear in my original video. By the
way, this conversation would go on for multiple days to give
null some criticism. He shouldn't have even tried engaging with
this guy. Adam is never going to change his position. Null should
have just called him a dog and left it at that. Now, I'm sure
you're well aware that my original video was briefly taken down
on YouTube. And I do think Adam had something to do with it.
He claims that showing a screenshot of his NSFW Twitter account
violates YouTube's community guidelines despite no actual content
being shown. I also never linked to it as some have claimed,
but coincident
>> uh I don't even know. Are you just like you're just
posting? Are you like high right now, baby poison, or are you
like drunk? Why mess just wins if he implies he will rip Rob's
media? I Okay, I don't Okay, I don't know what you're doing right
now. Are you good? Are you good,
>> Only a few hours after Adam released this Twitter statement,
my video was taken down. >> H suspicious. However, YouTube
claimed it was for showing a clip of null reading one of Adam's
own Reddit posts where he defends me. The funny thing was the
video where I got that clip from was still up, though it was
age restricted. So, I told sensitive >> Oh, obviously >> who
also made a video on this to take his video down so he wouldn't
risk getting a warning or a strike from YouTube. Adam would go
on to brag about the videos being taken down, lying by >> Yms
already said he's a sub though. Yms is gal hit difference as
BB poison.
He's already said he's a sub. He's he you don't operate like
that. Okay. Oh, hold on. Quick quick quick detour. Quick detour.
Okay. Hold on. Quick detour to Nandros's Twitter. Okay. Really?
Real Neandros. Okay. Quick detour to watch this clip real quick.
Okay. Adam talking about his Okay. Adam talking about his Don't
know if you guys saw this clip yet, but it is >> one of
the alltime greats. Okay. Hold on. One of the all-time great
clips. >> Um, so I got uh tendonitis.
This is Ieko Stardust Boax
and you'll be able to tell from the voice who the mask is. Okay,
no spoilers in the chat.
>> my ability to edit, but also I'm a human being who is,
you know, a human being because that's what human beings, most
human beings, not everyone are. Uh, and so I would also and I
was like, okay, well, this is probably hurting my uh wrist while
I'm trying to recover. I'm trying to I've literally got my like
wrists in like my hands in like immobilizers or what. >> So
he's he can't jerk off because of his RSI cuz his like wrists
are so okay. He literally can't jerk off. >> Like I probably
shouldn't be doing anything with them. But I don't know like
after a few days of like not coming then you're like oh you know
maybe I should. And then that the part of your brain takes over.
So I was like what am I going to do to stop this? And I'm in
a weird you know a lot of queer queer people weird community.
And so I'm I'm aware of things like chastity cages. And so I
was like, "Okay, I'll just do one of those." But then I couldn't
find one that fits me cuz I guess my too thick. And so I had
I bought like I went around looking like everywhere for like
a chassity cage that I could fit in. I I went on I went on a
website called lock
which is a Canadian website.
That's a
I don't know how the It's so crazy that somebody would be comfortable
saying any of these things with their face on. Bro, I would not
be comfortable saying this with like a VTuber avatar right now
with like a PNG tuber. I don't understand how you could have
your face there and put that on the record. It's crazy.
>> Yeah. and they had like every single and I and it measured
like the circumference of all of them and I got the biggest one.
It was still like pinching me and I couldn't use it. And so now
I have I love that he's also because he's talking about like
a cage nobody's even calling him on the fact like basically you've
proven okay for any other story you say you have a massive that
doesn't fit in some toy people call you out on that. Okay, but
this one is such a weird story to tell on a stream that people
are like, "You know what? I bet you're pissed that I I you know
what? I'm I'm not going to call you on that. There's no way you'd
tell this story if your balls weren't huge. Your must be, you
know, appropriately sized." >> I literally have like a
ziploc bag of like six different chastity cages that I have no
use for that I'm just going to like give away to somebody. How
>> How do those cages work? Like how does it make you come?
No, it's not about it's about preventing you from coming. >> Yes.
Uh, apparently Chud Logic was on this panel and very interested
to learn
>> He just he needed to know more.
Everybody else very aware of what's going on. Blocks not asking
questions. Blocks knows. Chad Logic very curious.
>> Hold on. Hold on. >> Bag of like six different
chastity cages that I have no use for that I'm just going to
like give away to somebody. >> How do those cages work?
Like how does it make you come? >> No, it's not about It's
about preventing you from coming. >> Oh, right. >> It's
about preventing you. >> So, it's it's well, it's preventing
you. It's It's supposed to keep you from getting hard, basically.
So, it's like you're supposed to put it on your flaccid PP.
>> It's you lock it or whatever. It's like a
device that stops you from getting hard.
I've also tried to use these
cuz like just like taking LWD pictures with them. I will I will
say though like I feel like they're not the most effective at
actually stopping you from getting harve
I've choked on before and just like puked all over them.
>> Okay, fantastic clip. We all know why Chud would be
so excited about that specific person saying that specific. Okay,
we all know exactly why.
it turns out he did actually react to it. Okay. And Nandra also
conveniently has that clip for us to somebody. >> How do
those cages work? Like, how does it make you
>> No, it's not about It's about preventing you from >> Wait,
that was me.
>> Oh, right. >> It's about preventing you.
>> It's It's Well, it's preventing you. It's It's supposed
to keep you from getting hard basically. So, it's like you're
supposed to put >> I didn't realize I was on this panel
>> and it would it's
like a
>> device that stops you from getting hard. >> I've
also tried to use these before
>> just like taking
pictures with them. I will say though like I feel like they're
not the most effective at actually stopping you from getting
hard. I've definitely embarrassed him. >> This [__]
round is all I'm >> I don't know, >> dude. He's I
feel like he remembers this. Okay. I feel like he might have
>> some portion of this audio saved somewhere. All right.
[__] round. >> I don't know
before and just like puked all over
classic. That's classic. That is classic, dude. Bro, I forgot
I was on that panel. I didn't realize that was me, dude. What?
I can't remember using this icon, dude. DUDE, THIS IS THAT'S
FAKE. That those reactions weren't real.
I That might be true. Although, did Nandros really photoshop
Chud's face or photoshop a different avatar of Chud that was
going through Discord? I don't even I don't know about that.
Clips like this that are the reason why Chud overcompensates
and starts being transphobic. Yeah, he's very shameful. He's
very ashamed, sorry. of being groomed into being a chaser, right?
That he he's only started engaging in leftwing politics and,
you know, a prerequisite of being, you know, a socialist communist
type on Twitch pole or in Twitch pole is being a chaser. And
so he was groomed into it. He was a part of that scene and he
had to. Okay. You gota you got to love girl to be in the demon
mama sphere of Twitch pole. Okay. And they were close friends.
>> That wasn't me doing that. He's putting that in there.
to stitch me up. Dude,
>> dude, that was so good that I was using this face, though.
That is >> I don't believe >> that wasn't actually
me. He's edited that in there. Dude, I forgot I was on a panel
with uh Your Movie Sucks.
No wonder you wanted me to watch this. >> I don't know,
man. >> I totally forgot about that. >> Can we find
Can we find
I don't know. I don't know. You cook? I'm not really Dude, I'm
not even saying anything crazy. Listen, he he has to overcompensate
now by being transphobic. That's the audience he's got. Okay?
But never believe it, okay? His heart his heart is not in it.
He's a very good actor, but his heart is not in it, and we can
all tell. All right. Anyway, back back to the YMS Rob's media
video where Rob is just going to first he's going to copy it.
He's got a couple different things. Okay. copy somebody else's
take from Twitter uh usually Nicholas's it seems like or tie
YMS or whoever he's attacking to U Denims Caseyron
Idubbbz Ana Destiny Vosch people he dislikes his audience dislikes
okay these are the tactics we'll see if there are any novel arguments
coming out I kind of doubt it all right I kind of doubt it >> to
make it seem like we took our videos down willingly though luckily
mine did go back up but it is age restricted Adam claims I'm
making this all up saying that it's common for YouTube to give
the incorrect reason for video removal. >> And then in
his community posts, he's he's saying that it was dinged for
a completely other reason. And Nick just kind of believes him
on that. Uh he shows that like, oh, the time stamps wrong on
the on the thing that they sent, which has happened to me a billion
times. Like anybody who's been on YouTube would know like if
you get if you get like any kind of like strike from YouTube
or you know, if you get anything from YouTube, more often than
not, the time stamps wrong, right? when I got dinged for having
like uh 9/11 footage in one of my videos as a joke like way back
when
uh I had to surf around cuz the time stamp they provided I was
like what that just leads to a random thing what then you have
to surf around and be like okay this is probably the issue either
Rob doesn't understand that or he's coping and lying it's kind
of weird >> maybe that was the case years ago but if my
video was removed for showing that Twitter username then why
is the claim for audio and not visual content how about read
the screenshots you stuck up little and how about you admit Jesus
Christ.
Uh, wait, hold on. Wait. >> Either Rob doesn't understand
that or >> I need to hear that again cuz is he saying that
there's no other audio or so there's no other possible audio
in that entire video that could have gotten hit? Cuz it sounds
like that's what he's saying,
which is just absurd. >> It's kind of weird. >> Maybe
that was the case years ago, but if my video was removed for
showing that Twitter username, then why is a claim for audio
and not visual content? How about read the screenshots, you suck
up little [__] And how about you? >> I I just
think I don't know if Adam's saying that. He's saying it could
be anything. Or he might have said that as an example, but it
just could be any of the audio anywhere where you're reading
over
[__] about sucking dogs. Any of the descriptions
of any of the audio descriptions of like his could easily be
it too. >> You admit to wanting my video removed or restricted
so less people can see it. You're very afraid of this becoming
mainstream, but all this did was enable the Strand effect. Adam's
other main tactic against me was to downplay the severity of
my video without directly showing my arguments. It once again
reminded me of Bosch, specifically his live stream response to
Ethan Klein, where he never actually shows any clips. Adam actually
does something similar. Not once in his hour and a half long
response video does he show a clip from my video. Instead, he
yaps on and on about how I'm bad faith. Okay. Okay. Okay. Okay.
This is
a possible shot that Rob could have. Okay. Because what you do
when you say they don't show clips, what you need to do, especially
if you're doing like an edited video essay, okay? What you should
do is you go and show how they intentionally took you out of
context to up your message or to Yeah. to like straw man you
to to make it seem like you were doing something other than you
were doing. So you can't just say he didn't show clips and leave
it there. You have to show why he didn't use clips. You have
to show why he chose that as a like basically you're arguing
he couldn't respond to what I said so he had to he had to distort
or dilute what I said to make it something he could respond to.
You have to show him distorting what you said intentionally to
make it uh something he could respond to. That's what you got
to do here. And this is a chance for for him to actually show
that Adam is lying or Adam had a bad response. I believe in you
Rob. I believe in you. I know you could do it. While giving vague
examples, he claims I left out context about why he argued with
null, the owner of Kiwi Farms. >> The context that was
left out of the original video is that I'm not arguing about
Carol the Wolf. I'm only in there because I was mentioned in
the video because people were comparing me. I think it was null
himself. Like this is a long time ago. I was only in there because
people were trying to connect the dots like Rob. >> Yet,
if you watch my original video, I do explain the context. The
funniest instance of this is when Adam started an argument of
Null, the owner of Kiwi Farms. after he uploaded a video in late
2018 talking about the zusadist wolf. In that video, he makes
a claim that Adam is part of the growing normalization for dogs.
But one time he does actually add context, it only makes him
look worse. When I brought up Adam engaging a shad man on Twitter,
he adds on worthless
>> As soon as he drew
Okay, now I need to listen to Adam again here. I'm paying attention.
It's just like tough to go back and see once he actually shows
what he said. I need to go back and see >> why he argued
with null, the owner of Kiwi Farms. The context that was left
out of the original video is that I'm not arguing about Carol
the Wolf. I'm only in there because I was mentioned in the video
because people were comparing me. I think it was null himself.
Like this is a long time ago. I was only in there because people
were trying to connect the dots like Rob. >> Yeah. And
if you watch my original
>> so the argument would be that
you you didn't have to tie him to a zeusist, right? The argument
is Rob is tying me to a zusatist to to somebody who like actually
wants to hurt animals, right? And that's wrong. I'm just defending
myself because no went after me. Now that that's what he's saying.
And let's just listen again to how Rob explains it. I do explain
the context. The funniest instance of this is when Adam started
an argument of Null, the owner of Kiwi Farms, after he uploaded
a video in late 2018 talking about the zusadist Wolf. In that
video, he makes a claim that Adam is part of a growing normalization
for [__] dogs. The one time he does actually add
>> I don't think any context left out there. I think that
is a like Rob is correct on that one. I don't think there's context
left out there. I don't think that was like super irresponsible.
I think that's Adam wanting things to be said the exact way he
wants them said. And realistically, I don't feel like I'm misled
there. What iota.
So yeah, I I don't know why Adam was so kind of like over critical
of that >> context. It only makes him look worse. When
I brought up Adam engaging a shad man on Twitter, he adds on
worthless >> As soon as he drew Keemstar's daughter, that
was the situation where he was no longer doing things that involved
consensual adults. He was involving people that were not consensual
adults. That's a clear line that was crossed. I don't think I
ever defended that ever.
Right. I don't I don't know. I don't think there's any interactions
of me and him after that point. And if there were, I probably
didn't know about that. >> Yeah, he interacted with Shadman
twice after this. The second occurrence was dug up and archived
by Kiwi Farms user following this response stream. He's giving
himself plausible deniability here, and he then downplays the
interaction I showcase in my video. I think there's literally
two interactions and both of them were me not responding just
directly to him, but you can see like three other people tagged
in all of these cuz there was a big comment thread and then I
would make a joke.
I remember I think we called Adam out even in his response like
we we called him out pretty quickly on this that like okay
you're asking him to draw like some for you. I made a joke like,
"Hey, drama." >> It's Oh, yeah. It was like the uh it was
the Darius like it's just a bit thing, right? Like I'm gonna
hate on I'm gonna hit on this woman and I'm gonna do it in a
like unhinged way or something in like a in like a way over the
top way. And if they like it, then okay, good. And if they don't,
then I'm going to say it's a joke. That's what he's doing there.
Like why don't you draw this for me? And he's like, "Well, I
wasn't saying it >> Horse persona getting railed by Scar
or whatever. Self-deprecating >> funny joke. if he didn't
have someone draw that exact same thing for you years later.
Alongside not showing clips, Adam has downplayed his past statements
in his Twitter response. He wrote, "10 to 15 years ago, I shared
my personal perspective on various controversial moral philosophical
issues. And because I was in my early, I didn't phrase myself
as well as I would today. I point out in my video that he was
still making these statements as recent as a year ago. Though
he spends his new response restating them in a more palatable
and optics friendly way. >> People have asked me, "How
is it possible for an animal to consent to a human being?" Right?
And my answer was the same way it consents to another animal.
Now, people have interpreted that as me saying animals want to
have with human beings and therefore it's all good or whatever.
People have interpreted that as me saying all
you know, it's it's still a man. The bad take here, he's not
going over the bad take. The bad take is just possible for an
animal and a human to have a relationship that's beneficial to
both of them >> towards animals are permissible because
of that. That is not my position.
You the pos. So he's
that's not that's not the closest you can get to the line or
sorry that's not sorry that would be the closest you get to the
line is is arguing that um what he just said that it like shouldn't
be permissible. He's he's like he's like weasled in between two
things. How do I describe this? He's he's basically he's saying,
"I don't want it to be legal, but you're you're arguing that
the act itself could be okay and nobody is going to essentially
nobody's going to actually like rock with you on that." Okay.
It's like a act util argument that like, well, you could possibly
a dog or have a dog you and and that wouldn't be harmful to the
dog, right? It's it's stupid. It's a stupid argument to make
even in the world where you want to be like the debate like oh
you know as long as you're not doing harm. I just I think it's
still a bad argument to make. It's still like a horrible looking
argument to make. My position is that sure it's possible right
when someone presents me with a this is 1,000% not possible.
And I go okay well it's probably possible. >> Despite this
he still claims there are ways that animals can consent to humans.
Meaning he hasn't learned jack. He claims that he was always
speaking from an animal's version of consent, meaning he's implying
that standard to humans. >> It's not informed consent,
right? It's not the human standard of consent. I was only ever
talking about the perspective of the animal, which people who
get really emotional about this. Just forget or don't have the
ability to wrap their heads around, right? >> Later in
the stream, he quadruples down on his take that there are certain
circumstances where it's okay for beastly audi to occur. >> To
reiterate, you know, having having sex with children is bad.
I don't want to see people having sex with animals. I would I
would prefer people not to. I would say in most cases it's probably
bad. There's some ways in which it's probably
not that bad. I don't know. Maybe not worth throwing someone
in jail over again.
You know, animal breeders
>> most it's most it's most he always does the same thing.
He's never adjusted this position that there's there are some
cases where it's not bad. >> Again, this is a scientific
thing. Shouldn't be controversial. >> What do you mean
by that? Despite this guy saying over and over again that he
doesn't support his, he always seems to allow exceptions. And
then a little birdie named Nick Andros sent me a link to his
old Silent Hill 2 playthrough where he gives a hypothetical about
quote unquote consensuals.
>> Goats are farm animals. I don't I don't see anything
wrong with having sex with a goat. >> I I just wish I think
we all wish he didn't say that. Okay. I think he wishes it. I
think we all wish it.
That's just a weird thing to say. Why the are you saying like
this? We should be able to rip the goat.
I didn't get to the worst part. I didn't get to the worst part.
You're able to eat them.
They're literally currency.
Which animal should you not be able to rap? Uh humans. Otherwise,
I I don't know. I'm not a support of animal. I'm a support of
of uh consensual
supporter of uh consensual.
I don't encourage it. I'm not going to convince someone to try
it. I've never tried it. I don't intend on ever trying it. But
I recognize that people exist that will live their whole lives
with an urge to do something like that. And
meanwhile, while every other person on the planet gets to fulfill
their eternal, psychological,
emotionally/physically
driven urg urges, these other people on the planet that are attracted
to the wrong thing somehow aren't able to do that despite not
harming animals in any way that they wouldn't be harmed through.
So I uh I don't know why
there's just this I I still haven't sat down to formulate it.
It's like this
obsession with uh consistency that happens from people, right?
It's like, well, you'd eat them or you would sell them. They
don't have like we don't allow them agency. We take their agency
away in like brutal ways. And so, it's also okay. And it's like
I don't know. There's just there is something there. I think
that there's this weird like um I don't know if it's like liberal
is the right word obsession with like trying to apply some kind
of
I don't know there there's like discuss sensitivity like cultural
disgust sensitivity around stuff that people want to ignore and
I think that enough is enough to make me go like you have to
like break those boundaries down slowly over time and so like
that and by the way not necessarily the animal I think more of
like the the counter point to that argument is gay people right
every time and it's like well you have to like let that get normalized
over time and have it like I don't know be accepted and we're
he's of the opinion we're like 10 to 20 years away from dog being
okay I just don't see it ever getting there right the desire
to animals a social harm it's so there's a couple arguments you
could make there I don't really want to go through them all that
much but um it's like you do the you could do the contagion argument
like basically that having that desire, continerate
on other things. You'll you'll you'll you know, even if if you
engage in in like degenerate behaviors, it will snowball almost.
He is the zoo file equivalent of the maps movement. Um I don't
know if he is. I I can't tell. He's right on the edge of being
an actual zoo file who's like trying to normalize it and like
somebody who's just got this like hyper way of looking at moral
philosophy,
right? He's like right at the intersection point of those two
things and it's hard to push him onto either side of it. It's
really easy to just go with the flow, go with the crowd and go,
"Well, that's gross. I'm going to push you off the cliff." Right?
It's easy to do that. Honestly, I like in my heart of hearts
probably lean in that direction. It's just like I don't know
if that's I don't know. He's like he's right at the the intersection
like I said. What if gay people never get normalized? At what
point what should be at that point? What should people do? Um
yeah, I mean it's tough. I think there's there's some argument
here that I feel like should apply where there's like a way there's
like a healthy way for society to shift, right? And that basically
if you're here's the issue is like there is some element of this
where Rob's sorry YMS's willingness to discuss this is so like
antisocial
that I think they're
I think heristically not in a way that you could legally handle
it but heristically I go oh well that's kind of concerning right
the fact that you would say these things feels kind of concerning
in terms of like what I trust you to trust you to do society
right you say that aren't You equating dogs to gay? No, you're
not equating dogs to gays. You're equating social taboos. Don't
do the thing that people did to Fentes. It's not It's not like
the same at all. You're discussing like social taboos. I'm not
totally sure. Evil Johnny Bravo. If we observed a thousand intelligent
alien species at our level of technology, how many would have
a no cultural aversion to animal? I do think there's a meta thing.
So,
uh, there's like a weird thing going on here where h
I don't know. I have to I have to think through think think through
it more. I don't know precisely
because there is definitely there's definitely another element
here of
like people were totally fine with slaves, right? Even though
you treated them like they were treated lesser than but I don't
think any of the societies that slaves ever did animal [__]
So like there is some element of oh he's like we treat them like
currency or we you know we allow them to be abused in different
ways. It's like okay but I think it's like I still don't know
what societies really don't have any taboo whatsoever on animal
[__] even with the Indians who the goat okay I'm
pretty sure most of India says don't rip goats I'm not sure how
much they follow through but I'm pretty sure through any other
activity you know to to to suggest that there's no such thing
as consensual human/an animals is to be the most naive person
on the planet dogs try to hump your leg that's all the evidence
I need I don't have to have sex with an animal to know that animals
don't have the same type of reservations human.
If it feels good, they're probably okay with it. If they try
to bite you or run away, that's probably a sign that they're
not okay with it. So, the argument that, oh, you can't tell if
it's consenting or not, even though it's clearly enjoying itself.
Okay, Cy, you're walking into like literally all of the liberal
traps, right? Like you just make people will just do the thought
experiment with you. It's like, oh, well, if you could prove
you could press a button that you wouldn't get a disease from
that dog. Is it okay to [__] that dog now? Right?
You're just walking into all of these. It's like super boring.
If you've ever watched any of the If you've ever watched YouTube
debate for like any amount of time, you probably understand like
all these arguments. And it's just like it feels pointless.
It feels pointless. Liberals do love justifying a moral. It's
like
it all comes down to like, oh well, you're you're not harming
anybody. I think um
I think the internet has turned me into like a virtue ethicist.
I think that's what I have to learn. Okay. I think I have to
go down that path. I think that's probably what life is. That's
probably the way to live. Okay. Such
I can't believe people I can't believe how much of society is
just dictated by people saying I don't like it or that's gross
or they're not a part of my tribe. It's disgusting to me. It's
disgusting to me. Human animal is not nearly as disgusting as
the mentality that discriminates against people who have never
abused animals that are attracted to him. Flaws. I'll say this
again. I went on this same rant in like 20 other videos.
laws are laws that exist that only affect people that are consensually
having sex with animals without abusing them. Animal abuse laws
already exist. If if somebody had sex with an animal and the
courts determined that the animal was abused by somebody having
with that animal, then they would already go to jail over animal
abuse lies. Laws that exist against
literally only affect
that's weird. It feels unsatisfying as a moral code. Um, I think
probably the it's not a positive thing. If you want to I I feel
like it's probably like if you want to violate a taboo, like
a social taboo, you probably need some positive utility. It has
to help people in the world, right? It has to like help something.
I don't know if there's any reason that you have to that you
would argue that you're helping the world by a dog. people who
were not abusing the animal.
So if somebody sucks the dog's or somebody evil Moody Juny
dog starts [__] their butt and they get caught, like
even if they just didn't move or whatever, even if they just
like lubed up and let the dog do what it wanted to do or something
and they got caught and the dog clearly wasn't abused and everybody
in the courtroom determined that there was no abuse taking place,
they would go to jail. That's what those laws are for. That's
what those laws are for. And it's disgusting to see that people
are openly willing to send people to jail for literally victimless
crimes. >> His fans soon start linking in his chat. >> Don't
post that. Don't don't post links. I'm pretty I'm pretty sure
certain states have laws against that. So I don't I don't want
I don't I don't want uh any of that. This is exactly it's concerning
to me. Canadian caller. Okay. It's concerning to me. Jane color
says bottoming bottoming for phto is crazy. Concerns me that
that's he is the sub. He is like the guy who does he's the sub.
He's the bottom. He's like and he's talking about the consent
situation. It's like bro I
ah dog
dog.
What utility does gay have? Uh I would assume gay is downstream
of gay romance, right? MRNA goyam exploder and having two people
who have a happy union probably leads to some economic utility.
I I think there I think there is actually a positive util argument
right that is like a natural expression of human love and I think
I think you can go that way. I think
right and the fact that it's between two
>> in this chat animated that's okay but I >> but
again I'm not sure >> I would ask that mods would regulate
to make sure I didn't even click on the link so I don't know
if what you posted was legit or not but I'm just saying
no actual animal in my chat please I don't I don't want that
>> this speech about animal consent goes on for another
10 minutes it's absurd I won't play the whole thing for time
sake but I promise you no context is being cut I I will link
the full video down below. It starts at 40 minutes in. This isn't
him joking around or something. He legitimately gets at one point.
>> Seriously, the world is up. The world is so up. We eat
and kill animals. We are discriminating against people. And the
only reason that people hold a different standard to it is because
they're attracted to something that other people aren't. And
that is what is absolutely disgusting about this. Anyway,
I'm passionate about it because it's huge, huge discrimination
going on right now. Here's Adam's response to someone asking
how is
>> so guys
is any different from that of a it's really vile and I don't
want to risk my video getting age restricted by reading it. I
know the term local gets overused but I >> Hey, I I said
this when I first watched that clip the the Silent Hill stuff.
It seems to me like he's got a personal investment in the topic
that goes beyond just like arguing. And I
I don't want to imply a lot more than that. It's just like, bro,
it's there. You are really invested in this and like the injustice
that's being done. It's like you or a friend. It's you or a friend,
and I'm not sure which. >> I do genuinely think of him
as one. Adam has the mindset that he's one response away from
owning the haters. People like me, Oscar, Nicholas Dioro, and
others who've covered the story, but the more he responds, the
worse the situation gets for him. He won't ever back down. He'll
keep justifying his past statements of a slightly different coat
of paint each time. Most of his YouTuber buddies aren't going
to back him up on this, which I bet is extremely blackmailing
for him right now. In fact, the only YouTubers I've seen stick
out for him are Destiny and Mr. Miss Manchi. He doesn't even
agree with Adam, by the way. He's only in support because he
is a massive ho against Nick, which is hopefully the only he
has right now. Much of this drama has been swept up by this Olivia
person. >> Oh, if only Rob cut to the the cage clip >> Adam's
top Janney, who runs the highlights channel and moderates a >> Hey
everyone, Olivia here. Thanks for watching as always. >> This
is who I'm in drama with, by the way. They're the person who
put together that GoFundMe to buy Adam his scars doll. They spent
the last several weeks removing Reddit posts discussing the >> Hey,
hey, hey. It's not a stall. There's no holes to Okay, it's not
a stall. It's just a life-siz scar. All right, it is not a doll.
>> While also posting cringe like this.
Now, if your next question is what stops him from strapping a
bad dragon to that thing, I don't know. Okay, I I haven't come
up with that answer yet. >> Person is trying to push Adam
into discussing politics. As if that went well the last time
he went on EAP. According to them, I'm just a right-wing homophobe
attacking Adam over harmless thought crimes, describing my video
as a nothing burger. Yet, if it was a nothing burger, these two
golems wouldn't be responding like this. And Adam can keep responding.
But don't expect me to do the same cuz surprisingly I have other
things to do than argue with this mentally unstable loser. So
in conclusion, this guy is gay. He jerks off to like This is
your job. This is your job. This is literally your job. What
the do you mean you have better things to do? Your job is literally
talking about these people. I think if you're going to like snark
these people, you have some responsibility to respond to the
criticisms they make of you. No, I'm just kind of above this.
No, you're not. It's literally your your like whole channel right
now is this. What do you mean you're above it? You're not above
it at all. Don't pretend. The >> lion. He thinks it's okay
for people to fornicate with animals and he's willing to slander
anyone who talks about it. He deserves all the hate he's getting
right now. And you know what? I'm just going to say it. Adam,
I'm glad I ruined your vacation. I'm glad I lived in your head
rentree for weeks. I mentally you buddy. >> Rob's media
just me and there's nothing I can do about it. >> After
some of the [__] you and your fans have said about
me, I'm glad to hear that your wrists were in excruciating pain
while you typed out your essays. You deserve it. I've thought
long and hard about this and with cyber bullying, you kind of
can't really stop it if you DON'T KNOW WHO IT'S coming from.
BUT MY BEST ADVICE, JUST IGNORE THEM. >> Just ignore me
calling you a pedophile.
Just ignore it. Did By the way, did this guy ignore it when Adam
kind of flipped it and was like, you're you're literally you're
literally exposing miners to like my like intentionally, right?
I warned you not to do it and you did it anyway and then Rob
just didn't respond, right? Is that cyber bullying, right? Oh,
wait. No, he totally responded multiple times,
but whatever. I You can't be mad at people for watching your
coverage of them. You can't be like, "Oh, you you shouldn't respond
to me and I shouldn't have to respond